we go  whoa baby Glade what is the president  doing in our front yard our entire world  is in grave danger I want you to come  with me on an expedition I'm not my  father he was the Explorer I know you  were just a kid when you went missing  but now you're all we got Mr clade I'm a  huge fan thank you of your dad  where in the world are we Ethan you  brought the dog he just wants to help  yeah  we are clearly in Uncharted Territory  wow  uh hello you probably don't understand a  word I'm saying of course I understand  you huh dad dad Grandpa I'm a grandpa  all the trees that have what is this  place the cliffs are alive and the  waters resolve the flesh off your bones  uh is this thing dangerous  [Music]  merchandise it  they're basically the same person  are you okay  let's get moving  you can do this Ethan it's just a  nightmare tunnel just be brave  [Music]  okay  no around me yeah  [Music]